[Music]
well if you buy eggs you probably notice
that the prize has gone up a lot and at
some stores you can't even find them
yeah and aside from inflation there's
something else causing these relatively
cheap items to become so expensive an
egg shortage Mary Jane beliesza joins us
live from the Smiths on Decatur and
Desert Inn to explain how this is
impacting local restaurants and bakeries
Mary Jane
oh well let me tell you Kirsten those I
spoke to are calling it The Great egg
hunt as consumers and local businesses
are having a hard time finding specific
eggs and dealing with Rising costs
I literally said the other day are the
chickens on strike because why can't I
get eggs it's a big challenge for Jill
Schlesinger owner of Starburst parlor
the only keto Bakery in town catering to
a specific group of customers like those
with Celiac or diabetes she says every
ingredient is crucial it just puts puts
our whole production like to a halt
because literally everything we're
baking daily has eggs in it Brian
wachter the vice president at the retail
association of Nevada cites ongoing
supply chain issues and new government
regulations which removes caged eggs in
the market by 2023 this was passed by
Nevada legislature last year so we do
have a decrease in Supply and we have an
increase in demand especially as folks
are looking for ways to reduce the
effective inflation on their budget plus
the spread of avian flu is impacting all
bird populations the USDA reports the
U.S has lost more than a million hen
laying eggs we are seeing the price of
commodity price of eggs increase is
starting to fluctuate in fact it's down
a little bit to where it was in Peak
kind of September and so we're seeing
that continue to move as certain bouts
of flu go through certain populations
but until we can start replacing those
birds population in those poultry
populations I'm afraid this is probably
something that's going to be with us for
a while literally calling upon any store
possible even like a local grocery store
will get like as much eggs as we can
from them because I have to keep
providing my service so we'll make it
through the great egg loss of 2022.
now Brian Walker tells me there are eggs
around you just might have to do some
shopping whether it's at Smith's or
Albertson's new food ads come out every
Wednesday so make sure you check the
Flyers to find out which store has
specific deals live in Spring Valley
Mary Jane beliesza 8 News Now